je décide quels produits nous présentons
dans tous nos magasins qui finiront chez
les consommateurs 24 h sur 24 au service
de nos clients bien aimé se choisit très
attentivement et de manière
conventionnelle
je passe beaucoup de mon temps à
décliner des propositions qui
proviennent de champs comme vous vous
voyez ce graphique
cette courbe verte augmente ou bien
reste la même chaque mois aucun problème
avec mon choix de produits vous savez ce
que qu ici le dire joy non pas du tout
qualité valeur commandité je vends des
produits abordables des produits de
pacotille et votre balle est en
plastique et la 1ère étrange